- You know, I had a kid
write me a letter once,
he said, "Dear Mr. Leno," he was about 12,
he said, "I told my
friends you're my uncle,
and on Sundays we go for
rides in your Lamborghini,"
and he goes on this whole thing.
- What?
- He said,
"Could you pick me up at my
house and gimme a ride to school
so my friends won't know I'm a liar."
- Oh, but you are.
- I said, but you are,
but you are a liar.
You are a liar.
But then, I just love the
fact he wrote me a letter.
So I called his parents
and I said, listen, when an
old guy picks up your kid
in a Italian car?
- Yeah, yeah, that's not okay.
- I said your son wants me
to give him a ride to school.
It's okay.
So I go to the house, I pick him up,
we pull up to the school, you know
the Lamborghini's got the
doors that come up like this.
He goes, "Bye Uncle Jay."
I go, "Okay, I'll see you later."
As I pull, I hear a kid go,
"He really is his uncle."
Now I'm like, oh, what a liar I am.
- What did I just do?
- Yeah, exactly.
- You're complicit.
- I am complicit in
this child, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- He's now in federal prison.
I don't know what happened
to the kid though.
- I'm sure. (laughs)